[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde créativité et folie ou le coup
de hache dans la tête a considérer le
temps long de la civilisation nous
vivons un grand moment de bouleversement
culturel scientifiques et politiques du
culte à la culture et aux cultural c'est
toute l'histoire de l'art de la crise de
l'art que nous observons même si les
chefs-d'oeuvre du passé demeurent des
vigiles artistiques des arts aux
sciences le 19e siècle consacre avec
Darwin l'origine animale de l'homme avec
Freud c'est l'inconscient qui éclaire sa
part d'intimité dans l'élucidation des
rêves on pourrait évoquer les autres
transformations de l'économie à la
physique quantique au 20e siècle et
résultant de toutes ces évolutions
l'exploration des neurosciences bat son
plein et imprime en quelque sorte un
rythme biologique à la psychologie
alors de tout cela et de manière
sommairement cadrée on pourrait
toutefois trouver un fil rouge
d'explication des lucidations un pari
d'humanisme aux évolutions passées et
présentes de notre Homo sapiens si on
accepte de se mettre à l'écoute de la
Parole folle cher au philosophes Michel
Foucault si l'on examine la part de
folie qui se tisse dans le caractère
sacré de la vie et dont le lien avec la
créativité semble scientifiquement
fondée en témoigne avec majesté la
créativité immortelle des grands
artistes mais pas que dans la mesure où
la créativité est aussi un oeuvre au
détour de ce qu'on peut appeler la
vulnérabilité humaine quand elle
s'exprime pour se libérer de ses
entraves et de ses tourments tout est
comme dans la vie en quelque sorte dès
lors que nous vivons pour
œuvrer pour faire quelque chose pour en
parler je vous présente mes invités
Raphaël Gaillard vous êtes psychiatre
vous êtes directeur du pôle hospitalo
universitaire de psychiatrie à l'hôpital
Sainte-Anne Camille lauravillé vous êtes
philosophe et psychanalyste
Clotilde le guide vous êtes
psychanalyste et philosophe Marc Lambron
vous êtes écrivain de l'Académie
française
[Musique]
alors vous venez de voir cette citation
de Diderot les grands artistes ont un
petit coup de hache dans la tête
commençons par cette citation qui donne
son titre Raphaël Gaillard à votre
dernier ouvrage qu'est-ce qu'elle nous
dit est plus personnellement qu'est-ce
qui vous a conduit à vos pencher sur ce
coup de hache
alors personnellement c'est avant tout
mon étonnement chaque matin renouvelé
devant la fréquence des troubles mentaux
pourquoi sont-ils si fréquents le pôle
que je dirige à Sainte-Anne reçoit à peu
près 12000 patients par an et peut-être
ne le savez-vous pas mais la
schizophrénie a faite à peu près 1% de
la population générale la dépression
touche une personne sur cinq sur
l'ensemble de sa vie donc pourquoi c'est
si fréquent
et quand on s'interroge sur cette
fréquence en ayant comme canevas dans
notre réflexion biologique le darwinisme
que vous avez évoqué on se dit qu'il y a
quelque chose qui porte les troubles
mentaux qui portent la folie qui en
ferait peut-être un avantage et
rapidement ce qu'il se dit ce qui se
pense c'est l'idée que folie et
créativité sont liées
et alors le coup de hache alors
évidemment Diderot l'exprime à sa façon
avec ce petit coup de hache dans la tête
et j'ai toujours été gêné par cette
hypothèse d'un lien entre folie
créativité parce qu'à la fois au
quotidien de mon exercice je vois bien
les liens entre folie et créativité et
en même temps au quotidien de mon
exercice je vois surtout des personnes
en grande souffrance et ma vocation de
médecins et de les soulager plutôt
qu'être fasciné par une hypothétique
créativité et donc j'ai voulu renouveler
cette question en tout cas m'y
confronter très concrètement et j'ai été
étonné découvrir que les sciences
différentes sciences l'épidémiologie la
génétique les neurosciences amènent à
renouveler la question notamment en
faisant un pas de côté c'est toujours
utile en matière de psy de faire un pas
de côté on constatant que ce lien il
existe il est avéré mais ça n'est pas un
lien de superposition c'est un lien de
parenté d'ailleurs dans le détail alors
cette créativité liée à l'esprit qui
déraille en quoi elle est présente dans
votre propre vocation Marc Lambron le
écrivain romancier
d'où ça vient pour vous demander
d'emblée si je ne suis pas un peu
dérangé en somme d'une certaine manière
écoutez d'abord je voudrais saluer le
livre de Raphaël gaillard qui est tout à
fait remarquable que d'ailleurs
l'Académie française a couronné
en décembre dernier dire aussi que
Raphaël gaillard anime une association
qui chaque année en janvier réunis je
crois 300 ou 350 psychiatre plus que ça
et ou 400 et chaque année en hommage à
Jean de lait qui était à la fois
psychiatre académicien et père de
Florence delay un académicien et est
entendu ce qui m'est arrivé début 2020
et j'en suis ressorti libre il est assez
rare d'être entendu par 400 psychiatres
à la fois avec c'est ce que disait
Thomas Bernhardt que la folie rendait
quelque part plus libre et bien c'est le
cas donc alors après auto-analyse je
voudrais quand même avoir la modestie de
parler des autres pour commencer parce
que ce qui intéresse un auteur qui est
d'abord un lecteur c'est précisément moi
ce qui m'intrigue je veux dire ce sont
alors partons du 19e siècle
écrivains ou des philosophes qui au
cours de leur vie et dans le début de
leur vie ne sont pas en quelque sorte
signalés comme comme étant sujet des
troubles mentaux et puis ça survient je
pense à deux dans le domaine allemand ou
germanique à Holderlin qui va passer les
30 dernières années de sa vie dans une
sorte des études
hébergée par un menuisier près d'une
écart qui est un des plus grands poètes
ou un Nietzsche
l'incident ou l'accident de Turin qui
voyant un cheval rudoyé dans la rue
verse dans un état qui semble-t-il va
devenir irréversible ça c'est assez
intéressant puis alors il y a puisque
nous sommes en France la question aussi
de la Naissance de la clinique c'est à
dire comment est-ce que au 19e siècle
essentiellement des étapes pathologiques
rencontrent des des praticiens et il y a
deux exemples éminents c'est Nerval et
c'est Maupassant qu'il est deux vont
être traités d'ailleurs par le même
docteur Blanche le célèbre docteur
Blanche
mais il semble vous nous le direz que
dans le cadre de Maupassant en tout cas
il y avait des raisons organiques
semble-t-il une syphilis qui dégénère et
qui déclenche des précisément cette
cette pathologie dans le cas de Nerval
c'est plus c'est moi c'est moi moins sûr
ça finit par un suicide on va rentrer
dans le détail alors Clotilde le guide
vous êtes psychanalyste comment ça se
manifeste ce coup de hache que je vous
le constatez dans votre exercice et même
dans votre vocation je trouve que ce
lien effectivement entre folie et
créativité et la façon dont rafale
gaillard propose de le réinterroger et
tout à fait précieux parce que c'est
vrai que on pourrait dire que d'un côté
il faut bien un grain de folie il faut
une certaine excentricité il faut
consentir à une forme de déraillement
pour créer quelque chose mais en même
temps quand on est psychiatre quand on
est psychanalyste et qu'on est confronté
à la psychose quand on confronté à des
patients qui sont hospitalisés qui sont
dans des états de grande vulnérabilités
psychiques on sait bien qu'on ne peut
pas effectivement juxtaposées
la créativité et la folie c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut savoir de quelle folie on
parle néanmoins je trouve intéressant
aussi de de penser la créativité comme
ce qui peut chez certains sujets
fragiles faire rempart à une certaine
folie même si c'est provisoirement qui
peut en quelque sorte faire tenir
quelque chose on peut penser à Camille
Claudel kick a pu quand même créer à pu
quand même se sortir d'un certain ravage
de sa relation folle avec Auguste Rodin
mais finalement la folie a été plus
forte et son sentiment de persécution la
emporter mais on voit quand même que la
puissance de ces sculptures la puissance
de de son style à avoir aussi avec
quelque chose de sa folie oui alors
comme il aura vidé vous êtes penché sur
cette question à travers les arts
j'aimerais avoir votre avis
déjà la spontanément je pense aux
artistes qui m'ont confié sans le
théâtre sans la peinture j'aurais versé
dans la folie et c'est quelque chose qui
m'a toujours
touchée mais au-delà de toucher
bouleverser et sans doute conduite à
cette interrogation qu'est-ce qui
distingue une oeuvre qui sauve
qu'une oeuvre que j'appellerais une
œuvre symbole
d'une oeuvre symptômes et je crois que
cette différence entre ce qui est de
l'ordre du symbole et de l'ordre du
symptôme
m'a vraiment intéressé et a été le point
de départ de mon questionnement sur le
sujet qu'est-ce que c'est que le sujet
humain donc c'est de l'artiste et
marquer par alors vous en parlez très
bien dans votre ouvrage rafale gaillard
par cette skise qui caractérise le sujet
humain par le fait d'être séparé de la
réalité et de ne pas la voir
parfaitement recouvert et refoulé cette
séparation et de devoir sans cesse jeter
un pont et c'est le fait de jeter un
pont l'acte créatif comme le fait de
jeter un pont de profiter de votre
science de l'Antiquité pour voir si vous
retrouvez ça dans l'Antiquité
c'est vrai que je suis une passionnée de
mythologie
alors il y a deux choses d'abord le coup
de hache dans la tête forcément vous en
parlez à la fin de votre livre c'est le
coup de hache que subit le malheureux
pour donner naissance à sa fille Athéna
et cette naissance à quelque chose
déminemment prometteur et créatif
puisque on voit naître une
femme qui détient un principe masculin
et elle n'est d'un homme qui a intégré
avalé carrément un principe féminin
métisse la ruse et donc vont se trouver
mis l'un en face de l'autre masculin et
féminin en miroir l'un de l'autre
contenant l'autre de soi et une promesse
de dialectique d'échanges de réciprocité
il me semble être posé à l'occasion de
cette naissance et le deuxième point
fois que j'ai dit ça il y en a quand
même un dans la il y en a plusieurs mais
il y en a un dans la mythologie on ne
cesse
pendant toute la toute une partie de la
tragédie on ne cesse de se demander si
il est fou victime de
d'un syndrome de persécution ou bien si
véritablement les herini lui court après
c'est au reste
et la résolution de la tragédie passe
par Athéna qui va inventer le premier
tribunal public
et donc voilà là il y a véritablement
création à création d'un nouvel ordre
politique et je m'étendrai pas davantage
ça vous interpelle Marc Lambron c'est
mythologie ce qui m'intéresse dans le
les premiers échanges c'est est-ce que
question est-ce que l'extraversion du
symptôme à travers une oeuvre d'art peut
être ça ne va triste
on parle au fond d'une oeuvre d'art
comme quelque chose qui serait presque
curatif enfin en tout cas qui serait
comme à l'exutoire ou une libération de
d'un trouble ou d'un tourment intérieur
et ça c'est le praticien ou les
philosophes qui peut-être peuvent nous
dire si si l'art soigne ou au contraire
si c'est une sorte de de pisalée et de
et de spirale
voilà sans sans
issue ou sans recours
alors l'art soigne enfin Gaïa oui l'art
soigné il y a beaucoup à dire de la
façon dont
se pont jeter dans cet exercice
ce tissage dans l'oeuvre d'art peut
permettre de consolider conduire
et
stabiliser ou même permettre d'accomplir
chez une personne fragile mais dans le
même temps j'ai une petite réticence
parce que
au motif de cette vertu potentielle de
là
il est volontiers dit qu'il faudrait ne
pas soigner
et voyez je reviens à ma contradiction
interne initiale il est volontiers dit
que
le chemin de résolution d'un trouble
mental ou d'une fragilité serait là et
pas le soin et ce discours là que tout
psychiatre a entendu chez ses patients
l'entourage de ses patients éloigne
c'est même patient des soins et donc
l'effet davantage souffrir donc j'ai
souscrit en même temps que je m'en méfie
avec good moi ce que je voudrais c'est
que on va parler un peu des traumatismes
etc mais je voudrais d'abord évoquer la
question de la jouissance
est-ce qu'il faut un petit coup de hache
pour être créatif et je voudrais vous
soumettre cette réflexion de Tchekhov
j'imagine que pour celui qui a goûté au
délice de la création artistique il
n'existe pas d'autres jouissances
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de Clotilde
un budget j'aime beaucoup de check-up
finalement c'est une phrase qui qui nous
touche on a envie d'y croire que la
création artistique procure une
jouissance qui qui est aussi
intensification de la vie de la pulsion
de vie mais c'est vrai que disons que au
cas par cas dans la clinique les choses
sont aussi plus complexes par exemple je
pense puisqu'on se demandait si cette
jouissance de la création elle soigne
est-ce qu'elle est curatrice par exemple
si on pense à Marguerite Duras quand
elle a écrit lol vestein bon elle écrit
sur un personnage qui est en proie une
forme de folie dont elle d'ailleurs elle
s'est inspirée pour ce personnage d'une
patiente qu'elle a vu dans un hôpital
psychiatrique lors d'un bal et
alors est-ce que l'écriture de
l'olvestein l'aide elle finalement à
faire tenir quelque chose de son propre
être et de son corps ou est-ce que
finalement ça la fragilise pas davantage
c'est-à-dire qu'à la fois elle a elle a
écrit un texte inouï qui nous traverse
chacun quand on le lit qui nous qui nous
fait éprouver une forme de ravissement
et elle témoigne après je trouve ça très
intéressant dans ces écrits dans son
journal que elle a eu du mal à en
revenir de ce texte qu'elle reste
habitées par lol et que après avoir
écrit le végétaï elle s'est mis à parler
d'elle-même à la troisième personne
c'est à dire qu'elle ne retrouvait plus
en quelque sorte son jeu et je trouve
que c'est intéressant parce que à partir
du témoignage singulier là de Duras on
aperçoit que effectivement il y a une
jouissance une jouissance inouïe dans la
création qui peut aller jusqu'à se
perdre soi-même se laisser traverser par
quelque chose et en même temps il y a
aussi un risque
pris par le sujet vous constatez cette
jouissance Raphaël gaillard
oui d'ailleurs est-ce que vous avez pris
de vous âge allez dire est-ce que ça
procurait une puissance chez vous
d'avoir écrit le coup de hache pardonnez
merci moi j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir
à écrire parce que mon écriture est une
écriture habituellement de scientifiques
et l'écriture de scientifique est une
écriture très pauvre
puisqu'elle a vocation uniquement à
transcrire des idées très simples et
poser des hypothèses auxquelles on
répond de la façon la plus simple et la
plus directe possible évidemment en
anglais donc j'ai pris du plaisir à
l'écriture et une sorte de vagabondage
qui n'est pas mon écriture scientifique
ensuite sur la question de la jouissance
là aussi nous pourrions répondre
à un grand riche par un grand russe
quand on lit par exemple les
descriptions que de soyez ce qu'il
faisait
de Laura de l'épilepsie Laura de
l'épilepsie c'est le c'est le premier
temps qui précède la crise d'épilepsie
qui décrit comme étant un moment d'une
félicité incroyable quelque chose que
personne d'autre ne peut connaître où on
peut parler probablement de jouissance
mais de jouissance même qui consiste là
à embrasser l'univers entier dans cette
excitation initiale de tous les neurones
qui fait les prémices de la crise
d'épilepsie et bien voilà un grand
auteur qui qui
décrit un mouvement pathologique
l'épilepsie qu'on lui souhaite pas comme
étant source d'une félicité infinie
et je me demande ce faisant si
on se trompe pas d'objectif en pensant
en termes de jouissance
parce que je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit
là que l'oeuvre se fasse il faut qu'elle
se tienne beaucoup plus qu'elles soient
la marque d'une jouisserie
j'ai rencontré une grande dame de la
peinture qui habitait dans un faubourg
de Jérusalem elle avait une maladie de
Parkinson très accusé et très tôt mais
quand elle peignait sa disparaissait
complètement
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez en déduire
alors je vais pas en déduire grand chose
sans connaître la grande dame en
question mais c'est une impression parce
qu'on dit que
deux choses d'abord dans la clinique de
la maladie de Parkinson
le tremblement est un tremblement qui
est classiquement s'arrête à l'action
c'est-à-dire c'est quelque chose qui
entrave sauf au moment de l'action et
par exemple nous avons vu des des
chirurgiens continuent à opérer et bien
opérer étant pourtant atteindre maladie
de parknotes c'est-à-dire dans l'action
même quelque chose
se remet en place et puis ensuite il y a
une sorte de de mémoire du corps de
quelque chose qui qui traverse
l'individu qui à ce moment là le maître
en mouvement
en passant outre le handicap qui est un
handicap très moteur dans la maladie de
Parkinson et donc c'est pas très
étonnant d'avoir ce ces moments
paradoxaux de grandes fluidités motrices
chez une personne par ailleurs très
handicapée qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
cette sublimation par les arbres qui
veut dire un mot là-dessus marque
l'ombre peut-être je sais pas si c'est
seulement de la sublimation il me semble
que quand on est prenons le cas des
auteurs des écrivains je crois qu'il y a
plusieurs situations en plusieurs
postures par rapport à la folie il me
semble que ce qu'on appelle la folie
nous commençons à parler de ce des
souvent des grands artistes ou des
grands auteurs qui ont été comme qui
écrivent depuis la fournaise d'un d'un
état intérieur ça peut être Nietzsche ça
peut être le homal comme on disait au
19e siècle c'est-à-dire l'épilepsie et
le cas d'Arto est évidemment pris en
compte d'ailleurs par la clinique et on
peut parler de ce qui était la clinique
à ce moment-là et du rapport il en sort
et de ce qui décrit quand il en sort
d'ailleurs bon donc ça c'est la première
chose et à mon avis ça s'accompagne
quand même des tas de souffrance
intérieure donc là question de la
jouissance à mon avis elle n'est pas là
il y a une deuxième famille d'écrivain
et vous les voulez vous les évoquez dans
votre livre ce ceux qui mettons
Saint-Esprit
entre guillemets c'est c'est est-ce
qu'on peut appeler des psychoses
expérimentales c'est à dire les
stupéfiants les drogues et il y a des
écrivains éminents qui n'ont jamais été
regardés comme fou au sens clinique qui
sont par exemple
les portes de la perception qui sont
Michaud dont de vous parler des écrits
escadiens de Michao et même junger le le
Prussien junger qui écrit dans les
années 70 un livre qui s'appelle
approche drogue et il reste qui sont des
relevés ce qu'elle fait Walter banyamine
d'ailleurs avant lui il y a des textes
de voitures magnanime sur le haschich et
sur la morphine je crois bon donc ces
écrivains là qui en reviennent qui n'ont
pas être traités ils vont chercher
quelque chose en tout cas ce sont des
des voleurs de feu ou ça fait partie de
leur stratégie mettons d'écriture que
d'aller vers des états
psychique provoquait sous substance et
puis il y a une dernière
une dernière façon de s'approcher de la
folie qui qui serait peut-être la mienne
dans quelques-uns de mes livres c'est en
toute connaissance de cause inventé un
personnage un peu Sinok si vous me
permettez de l'expression prenez Malraux
par exemple Malraux était lui-même
évidemment sujet à toutes sortes de
d'états polymorphes mais il y a dans son
oeuvre un personnage qui s'appelle
clapique et classique qui décides je me
trompe dans la condition humaine et puis
on le revoit 30 ans plus tard dans des
Antibes qui est une sorte de d'illuminer
une coloniale qui vit au milieu des
tribus et qui a un discours très très
efflorescent très délirant Malraux
adores ce qu'il appelait les farfelus
bon et là on voit qu'il y a un plaisir
pour le coup je pense qu'il y a une
jouissance d'écrivains depuis un socle
de tout de même de rationalité à inventé
un délirant donc il y a plusieurs
régimes d'écriture et plusieurs
approches de la de la plusieurs
possibilités dans la gamme
vous constatez cette jouissance là je
voudrais pour suivre cette typologie de
du rapport à l'écriture et à la folie il
y a aussi certains écrivains mais c'est
très rare qui témoigne dans leur
écriture même d'un moment de folie
véritable et non pas de psychose
provoquées par les stupéfiants c'est à
dire de recherche d'un état au fond de
de de
une sorte d'extase qui leur permettrait
de créer je pense quand même à un
témoignage qui est rare et moi
cliniquement ça m'a beaucoup intéressé
je sais pas ce que rafale Gaïa va en
penser mais le témoignage d'Emmanuel
carraire dans son livre yoga bon
Emmanuel Carrère a écrit le royaume on
peut dire que il y a un effet là de
sublimation
ou il parvient à être connu comme au
moment où le livre sort comme
surplombant la rentrée littéraire donc
il y a quelque chose du grand auteur il
parle de cette nomination de grand
auteurs qui qui lui fait un certain
effet de jouissance et c'est assez
extraordinaire quand même le courage
qu'il a eu dans yoga de témoigner de
quelque chose finalement qui n'a pas
tenu pour lui de ce moment
d'effondrement mélancolique bon il
décrit pas toute la causalité puisque il
la garde pour son histoire intime mais
il décrit quand même ce ce moment de
souffrance intense ou effectivement il
demande à être soigné il me demande pas
juste il ne cherche pas là à s'en sortir
par la création au moment où il dans cet
effondrement mélancolie il faut qu'il
soit soigné pour pouvoir écrire à
nouveau
par exemple
et même chez Philippe Labro prenait un
auteur comme qui a écrit assez
courageusement sur ces sur cette
dépression voilà qui écrivent au coeur
d'eux et là qui sont comme des des
témoins des téléscripteurs en quelque
sorte qu'il ose dire en tout cas des
témoins des diaristes d'État intérieur
douloureux et souvent capable d'ailleurs
merci
[Musique]
alors Camille Laura Villé vous êtes
intéressé dans votre travail sur les
armes notamment sur Brancusi
sur la question de l'héritage et de
l'identité alors vous voyez ce que dit
Picasso un peintre a toujours un père et
une mère il ne sort pas du néant est-ce
que vous pensez que là la folie ne sort
pas du néant
je pense que la folie je dirais comme ça
c'est l'épreuve du néant qui ne peut
être surmonté
l'homme est traversé constamment par le
néant c'est son défi en tant qu'homme
que de vos que de devoir le surmonter
que de devoir à partir de ce néant qui
le traverse tisser quelque chose faire
émerger ce que j'appelle le Logos la
parole qu'on a traduit souvent par
raison
et il n'y arrive pas forcément alors
prolonger cette question du néant
Raphaël gaillard d'après René Char les
êtres blessés ont plus facilement accès
aux sphère dire supérieur en tout cas
disons à une intelligence plus proche du
Soleil comment vous axes vous expliquer
cet accès privilégié
chez les personnes qui sont un peu
fêlées je peux dire vers
la lucidité blessure la plus rapprochée
du soleil je
[Musique]
en fait je persévère dans
mon souhait de faire un pas de côté
parce que
je pense en fait que
plutôt que
aller chercher forcément chez l'artiste
ce qui fait chez lui
un cassis singulier
ce qui
pourrait être l'origine de son oeuvre je
pense qu'il vaut mieux qu'on s'intéresse
à ce qu'il représente de nos facultés à
nous tous être humain et évidemment il y
a quelque chose d'exacerbé chez
l'artiste évidemment qui est quelque
chose qui est
radicalisée par rapport aux communs des
mortels mais je pense que c'est plus
intéressant d'aller regarder ce qui
appartient
aux êtres humains et qui n'est pas le
seul fait de l'artiste et donc ce pas de
côté il nécessite de considérer que ça
n'est pas toujours
folie créativité mais qu'est-ce qui
pourrait exister qui lit folie et
créativité je pense que si on se décale
un tout petit peu la réflexion nous
permet de ne pas simplement considérer
tous ces artistes qui manifestement un
petit coup de hache dans la tête ou bien
la question de l'accomplissement comme
nous y avons réfléchi dans une oeuvre
d'art pour une personne ayant une
vulnérabilité pour un trouble mental et
ce qu'elle peut
consolider en quoi elle est elle était
thérapeutique je pense que l'idée qu'il
puisse y avoir chez chacun
une faculté à perdre la raison en tout
cas dérivé
[Musique]
nous éloigner du réel
et par là aussi créer quelque chose
et donc nous autres être humain
puissions à la fois créer et nous perdre
ça ce serait peut-être le lien qui nous
intéresse pour revisiter cette question
faut y être créatif alors cet homme très
bien on va parler du commun des mortels
[Musique]
qui possède souvent un grain de folie
bon les troubles mentaux font partie de
la condition humaine
Clotilde leggy let's go quand vous êtes
à l'écoute de cette parole folle si je
puis dire dont parle Foucault
comment on en sort pour ne pas s'égarer
dans la folie alors je peux vous aider
en vous disant que Philippe rot à propos
de sa dépression il dit que le supplice
épouvantable s'avéra libérateur alors
comment dire que moi je vous avais
prononcé là le terme important c'est le
terme de parole il me semble que la
folie
c'est pas moi je l'aborderai pas
nécessairement comme un rapport au néant
je l'aborderai plutôt depuis bon la
référence qui est la mienne celle de de
la psychanalyse la cannienne celle de ce
que dit laquant sur la folie très tôt
d'ailleurs dès 1946 dans des débats avec
Henri que vous citez aussi c'est que le
la folie à avoir avec la signification
elle a à avoir avec un certain rapport
au sens elle a avoir avec une souffrance
qui est liée au sens que l'on peut
donner à ce qui nous arrive une
souffrance qui est liée au fond à la
façon dont la parole de l'autre peut
nous percuter et ouvrir une faille dans
nos traits la façon dont nous pouvons
nous sentir persécutés par une parole la
folie elle a donc à voir avec la
dimension de l'interprétation et
effectivement il y a quelque chose de
l'ordre d'une faille qui peut s'ouvrir
chez certains sujets dans ce rapport à
la signification et qui peut ouvrir sur
une dimension délirante alors je
distinguerai disons la faille qui existe
en chacun dans le rapport à la parole et
à ce qui peut nous faire souffrir de ce
qui nous revient des paroles des autres
et puis cette faille qui peut
confronter un sujet à une forme de trou
une forme de disparition subjective et
qui fait en effet qu'il va ne plus
reconnaître si vous voulez ses propres
productions psychiques dans dans ses
pensées dans dans les hallucinations qui
qui vont la saillir dans les
automatismes mentaux dont il va être la
proie mais tout ça je le définirais
enfin c'est c'est manifestations de la
folie depuis un certain rapport à la
parole et au langage et en font
rencontrer le fou c'est déjà rencontré
une certaine parole et pouvoir laisser
aussi le sujet témoigner de ce qui lui
arrive alors Marc LAN don je voudrais
pas
mettre dans un schéma qui s'offrénique
dans ta par les Raphaël gaillard mais
vous êtes romancier est-ce que les
personnages
que vous inventez que vous créez
viennent interpréter si je puis dire
ce qu'on vient d'évoquer et est-ce que
c'est plus facile à travers des
personnages qu'à travers vous-même par
exemple qui est l'écrivain
de corriger ces failles et de les mettre
de les normaliser en quelque sorte parce
que on pourrait prendre peut-être
l'artiste comme faussaire c'est-à-dire
il peut y avoir des bénéfices de la
folie simulée
on parle de Picasso mes yeux prenez
quelqu'un comme Dali par exemple
Salvador Dali est-ce que vous allez le
caractériser comme un personnage insensé
ou est-ce qu'il n'y a pas une part
d'histrionisme
jouissive chez lui qui précisément quand
un personnage qui va être cet Avida
dollar dont d'en parler les surréalistes
si vous prenez le rock par exemple et
les groupes de hard rock la façon dont
scéniquement très souvent il y a une
sorte de
de folie Dion DIAC qui est organisée
mais qui est parfaitement contrôlé avec
toutes les postures toutes les donc
voilà une folie et on parle on dit voilà
ce concert était fou etc qui en réalité
tout à fait incorporée dans des circuits
de commerciaux et même quand plus
modestement quand j'étais jeune et qu'il
y avait encore un service militaire il y
avait un certain nombre de mes
contemporains qui simulaient des qui
apprenaient au fond qui prenait des
fiches sur qu'est-ce que c'est que tel
pathologie ou telle symptômes pour être
informé je crois P4 ou enfin il y avait
des il y avait une une nosographie donc
c'est assez intéressé d'entendre
là-dessus sur la folie qui peut être
instrumentalisée et qui peut être simulé
et qui peut être après tout jouissive ou
libératrice parce que faire le fou fou
comme on dit des enfants ça peut aussi
être agréable voir libérateur alors
voire rémunérateur
en continuant là-dessus
à propos de cette folie créatrice
le la part du traumatisme
on dit que le trauma est la folie et la
création quelquefois en partie liées
dans une échange avec le conservateur de
musée Jean Clair il observait qu'après
la guerre
on avait un certain retour dans la
peinture à la figuration
qu'est-ce que ça évoque pour vous
c'est-à-dire
retrouver le sens de l'humain après le
traumatisme
on a besoin de ça
je pense que l'homme est profondément
inachevé et que un truc comme le
traumatisme qui survient au cours d'une
guerre peut ébranler si fortement cette
image la conscience d'une identité qu'il
est nécessaire de la réinventer d'où
peut-être le le besoin de reformuler les
contours d'une d'une figure et
incontestablement les les arts
réfractent les traumatismes le
traumatisme peut être
une sorte de de
catalyseur mais également ce qu'il va
falloir mettre à distance
conjurer par l'exercice de la récemment
l'exposition cocochka m'a beaucoup
troublé au musée au Musée d'Art model
grande exposition
toute la période de la guerre on sent
une défiguration là pour le coup c'est
pas la guerre ou la figure va pouvoir
revenir et il y a une défiguration et
j'ai même trouvé c'est très très
personnel mais une comme une une laideur
mais pas une laideur au sens d'un
mauvais paintre une laideur au sens de
comme si la laideur du monde s'emparer
du Pasto du peintre donc le traumatisme
vient parler
peut-être que les artistes justement
parce qu'ils ont cette extrême
sensibilité
touche à certains moments ce que les
philosophes appellent l'immédiate tes
sensible ils reviennent donc ils sont
la médiation est réduite à presque zéro
et ils vont comme réfracter ce qui se
joue autour d'eux
je pense que dans le traumatisme de la
guerre il y a quelque chose
effectivement qui qui désorganise ce qui
fait perdre
la forme et les structures on pourrait
considérer que le modèle même de
l'expérience de la guerre c'est la bombe
à fragmentation
et on conçoit que la réponse à cette
fragmentation
cette perte des contours soit
une forme de figuration de retour à la
forme
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure
quelque chose de l'ordre du symbole
c'est-à-dire quelque chose qui suivant
l'étymologie du mot symbole vient unir
faire un chemin commun
comme vous le savez l'antonyme serait le
mot diabolique et donc on voit bien
comment il y a un effort de synthèse
dans dans la possibilité de penser
quelque chose qui figure et qui
matérialise là où jusqu'ici c'était la
fragmentation
en tout cas dans l'expérience du
traumatisme de guerre cliniquement là je
parle en clinicien
ce qui est toujours frappant c'est la
reviviscence
c'est-à-dire que les personnes ayant
connu la guerre
revivre ce qu'ils ont traversé comme au
moment présent il suffit d'entendre une
détonation une porte qui claque pour
qu'il soit à l'instant même comme ils
étaient sous les bombes c'est-à-dire
quelque chose qui anime le temps et en
même temps que ça ni le temps ça annule
l'espace il y a quelque chose qui les
plonge là où ils étaient et donc le
travail est un travail de reconstitution
finalement d'une trame narrative
d'ailleurs beaucoup de nos démarches
psychothérapes thérapeutiques
fonctionnent autour de cette perspective
narrative pour permettre une forme de
synthèse j'utiliserai à nouveau le mot
symbolique qui qui leur permettent de de
reconstruire quelque chose et quant à la
mise en scène dans Marc Lambron parlait
je pense que là aussi il faut il faut
bien penser que pour mettre en scène
projetée il faut quand même avoir une
intuition de ce que vit le personnage
donc cette c'est l'animé le romancier
comme des murs et qui et qui qui donne
vie à ce personnage qui lui échappe un
peu une sorte de Frankenstein mais il y
a quand même quelque chose qui qui lui
prête de lui
en psychiatrie nous utilisons le terme
de sursimulation la surcimulation c'est
c'est l'idée que ce n'est pas que simulé
c'est avoir vécu quelque chose que l'on
simule en plus et peut-être qu'il y
aurait quelque chose de cet ordre qu'il
a aussi est un chemin vers une existence
hors de soi qui qui pose des grands cas
donc dans le temps dans l'espace là où
les choses a été fragmenté
dans l'expérience de la guerre par
exemple alors Clotilde le guide sans
faire de la psychanalyse sauvage par
rapport à ce qui vient d'être dit cette
reconstruction après le désastre si je
puis dire est-ce qu'en psychanalyse
c'est pas un peu le cheminement
c'est-à-dire en déconstruit on
revisite ces traumatismes mais ensuite
il faut reconstruire il y a un
cheminement de cet ordre oui et
d'ailleurs certains artistes qui se
confrontent à leur trauma ou aux
traumatisme de guerre comme on venait
d'en parler nous apprennent aussi
quelque chose sur ce qu'est le chemin
d'une analyse le chemin d'une analyse je
dirais qu'il va il va consister à
pouvoir déchiffrer quelque chose de son
trauma jusqu'à affronter
ce qui va être de l'ordre de l'indicible
du traumas il s'agira pas seulement de
pouvoir dire mais de pouvoir
pousser les frontières de l'indici pour
pouvoir déchiffrer des traces qui ont
avoir avec ce qui s'est disons écrit
dans le corps même du sujet et je pense
en vous écoutant sur la guerre je pense
à au parcours de l'artiste allemand
Richter
sur lequel il y a eu un très beau film
qui s'intitule l'oeuvre sans auteur qui
est un peu passée inaperçue en France et
justement qui qui témoigne de cette
rencontre à la fois avec la folie dans
la famille pas sa propre folie à lui
mais la folie de sa tante et la question
du trauma infantile très rapidement
c'est un un garçon nous qui qui découvre
l'art sous le nazisme grâce à sa tante
qu'il emmène à l'âge de 6 ans voir une
exposition qui est qualifiée d'art des
générez et sa tante en fait va faire une
bouffée délirante aiguë suite au fait
d'avoir remis un bouquet d'avoir été
pour remettre un bouquet au Führer
sous ses yeux il voit sa tente arrêter
et emmenée par les services
psychiatriques qui sont aussi entre les
mains de la politique nazie et en fait
tout le parcours de Richter va consister
à essayer de trouver comme en peindre
comment trouver son style comment dire
quelque chose de cet événement où il a
vu ça il a 6 ans et il voit sa tante qui
lui est arrachée qui lui a fait
découvrir l'art et en même temps avec
qui il ne peut plus parler et je trouve
que c'est un très beau film sur ce
qu'est la création justement puisqu'elle
est rencontre là avec la folie de
l'autre et en même temps il va chercher
dans la figuration justement dans un
moment où à l'école d'art du soldator la
figuration n'est plus tellement à la
mode et il cherche dans la figuration
une solution pour dire quelque chose de
ce trauma qui qui l'a laissé sans voix
dont la mère lui est arrachée dans les
années 30 internets psychiatrique
n'arrivera jamais je crois qu'elle meurt
en 1941 en détention donc ça donne
Richter ça donne ce Stockhausen bon
alors après là
l'arrêt la folie si on veut il y a quand
même non au 20e siècle en tout cas des
mises en cause d'un certain usage de la
psychiatrie et ça n'est pas mal parce
que la psychiatrie eugéniste du régime
nazi la psychiatrie carcérale du régime
soviétique bon ça donne notamment ce
génitine il y a d'ailleurs des films où
le le psychiatre ou l'asile apparaît
comme un lieu
méphistophélique choc corridor ou Vol
au-dessus d'un nid de coucou qui qui
sont des Infiltrés des journalistes qui
veulent aller enquêter et puis qui
finalement vont rester prisonnier enfin
bon ils vont ils vont passer de de
l'autre côté et il y a eu même des des
correctifs si l'on veut interne c'est à
dire très bien dans les années 70 de ce
qu'on a appelé l'antipsychiatrique
d'ailleurs basalia en Italie langue
couper etc qui était comme une façon et
même guatari de deux en France donc il y
a aussi cela dans leur comment je dans
l'histoire du du fou entre guillemets et
du regard du comporte sur la folie sur
la façon de la traiter Marc Lambron
juste un mot quand vous écrivez
il y a des moments de blocage qui
arrivent c'est-à-dire est-ce que comment
vous les surmonter
que les rêves viennent nous avons peu
parlé des rêves c'est très intéressant
parce que ce sont évidemment des images
des raisonnables qui sont produites par
des personnages nous tous qu'on peut
regarder comme normaux donc c'est assez
intéressant cette cette c'était
florescence de de folle de l'esprit qui
pour autant ne porte pas à conséquence
quand on se réveille donc nous avons et
ça depuis l'Antiquité il y a des textes
très très qui très tôt de témoignent de
cela et c'est alors effroi évidemment va
sur la science des rêves en tout cas
c'est une des portes d'entrée dans dans
la dans la descente
finalement la création est comme un rêve
sauf qu'elle va pouvoir rejoindre le de
l'autre et toucher
on va terminer là-dessus sur une
question que vous évoquez dans votre
livre et que beaucoup de gens
se posent la question
cette folie créatrice est-ce qu'elle se
transmet de génération en génération et
selon quel mode de transmission parce
que vous avez
beaucoup de débats des gens qui pensent
qu'il y a des gènes de l'autisme de Jana
schizophrénie des gens qui pensent qu'il
y a des jeunes pour tout mais vous à
votre avis comment tout ça se transmet
en tout cas ce qu'on peut dire
dans les termes de la science
premièrement c'est évidemment il y a pas
de gêne de la schizophrénie comme il
existe un gène de la mucoviscidose et
donc de transmission génétique comme ils
disent une transmission de la
mucoviscidose pour autant il y a des
gènes de vulnérabilité aux troubles
mentaux et c'est justement intéressant
de constater que par exemple la
probabilité d'exercer un métier créatif
ce qui est une mesure assez grossière de
la créativité mais bon elle vaut ce
qu'elle vaut la probabilité d'exercer un
métier créatif elle est plus élevée chez
les parents frère et sœur et enfants
d'une personne souffrant d'un trouble
mental que chez cette personne elle-même
vous voyez qu'on fait ce pas de côté et
on constate que ce lien est un lien de
parenté d'ailleurs on l'a évoqué pas
forcément à la génération qui suit ça
forcément et peut-être même davantage
encore la génération dessus
toute la fratrie bien sûr là on l'a
évoqué pour Richter ou Stockhausen mais
la littérature ou l'histoire des des
hommes et des femmes fourmis de ces
représentations il y aurait quelque
chose comme un air de famille et encore
une fois c'est plus intéressant de
penser en termes d'air de famille autour
de la créativité plutôt que de façon
forcenée aller chercher quelque chose
qui superpose folie créativité qui qui
vient exiger des patients souffrant de
troubles mentaux qui deviennent créatifs
c'est une sorte de double peine il
faudrait en plus de souffrir d'un
trouble mental se révéler créatif ou
bien assumer tout artiste d'une
étiquette diagnostique en disant puis
c'est un artiste il a tel ou tel
diagnostic alors que
Marc lambrons nous a bien expliqué que
devant 4000 psychiatres congrès dans ses
fans
4000 vous avez été trop modeste vous
êtes sortis vous êtes sortis et même
très applaudis oui alors écoutez juste
sur ce point il y a quand même une
démonisation qui était le discours sur
le latar les taré on voit ça chez Zola
par exemple sur les les lignages les
filiales et la la malédiction dire le
fatum qui devient organique en passant
par le fait qu'on soit taré et que
l'alcool etc ça se transmet je pense que
tout ça est démenti tout même là
écoutez j'aurais terminé cette émission
je voudrais pas
sexuée le débat ou le champ ré mais je
vais vous poser une question
à vous Clotilde le guide à vous Camille
lauravillé pour terminer cette émission
est-ce qu'il faut accepter de se perdre
pour faire
œuvre notamment dans la relation
amoureuse
moi j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur
ce que là quand appelle la folie
féminine donc j'aime beaucoup cette idée
que finalement dans l'amour
effectivement on peut consentir à une
forme de perte et que c'est même la
définition du consentement ce
dessaisissement
néanmoins il y a aussi une dimension de
ravage dans l'amour qu'il ne faut pas
méconnaître et qui a été aussi au cœur
de de ce qui est intéressé Lacan sur la
façon dont aussi
l'amour peut rendre une femme folle et
vous comme il aura vidé alors moi je
dirais
[Musique]
se perdre peut-être pas mais
s'abandonner sûrement au sens de l'essai
de la conscience de soi pour aller
rejoindre son autre et je pense que
l'homme qu'on choisit d'aimer mais je
pense que pour les hommes c'est pareil
peut-être que là c'est un point on se
rejoint
bon j'assure mais que l'homme qu'on
choisit d'aimer
il n'y a pas de hasard il vient il est
là pour nous révéler quelque chose et si
on s'abandonne pas à lui
je vais pas je vais pas empêcher les
hommes d'intervenir croyez qu'il faut il
faut se perdre pour être amoureux
Raphaël
un peu
beaucoup passionnément à la folie vous
voulez vous dire oui
un peu beaucoup passionnément la folie
Stein
qui est un livre on peut dire d'amour et
dans ravissement il y a le fait d'être
ravi au sens de la jubilation de fait
d'être enlevé aussi d'être emporté et on
pourrait faire du néologisme la cannière
en disant ravissement ravagement
vous alliez aussi du côté du ravage donc
ça commence par Rav comme une rêve
partie
amoureuse
on finit avec cette lève l'amour fou
je crois qu'il y en a un fantôme
suggérer une bibliographie alors je
commencerai évidemment pas
Raphaël gaillard donc vous avez publié
ce fameux coup de hache dans la tête et
juste une impression depuis que le livre
était publié parce qu'il y a une année
je crois il y a quelque chose a évolué
chez vous par rapport
cette publication
est-ce que vous des commentaires que
vous avez reçu des éloges des critiques
etc pour il y a quelque chose de
personnellement mais c'est pas le plus
important c'est c'est la chance de
rencontres telles que celle-ci mais je
pense que au-delà de ma propre personne
qui n'est pas très importante c'est
aussi la possibilité de changer le
regard sur ceux qui chantent qui
souffrent de troubles mentaux et et
puisque ce lien entre folie créativité
est avérée mais est avéré différemment
comme un lien de famille comme un lien
de parenté je crois que ça nous amène à
placer ces personnes au centre de la
société et pas dans une position
excentrique marginale comment la trop
fait merci oui si je la cannisme alors
là vous allez ne la canalisez pas parce
que ça sera trop long
et
Raphaël est aussi un pionnier on peut
dire de la biopsychiatrie me semble-t-il
on peut appeler ça comme ça bon alors
Markland vous avez publié le monde
d'avant bon bientôt ça sera le monde de
demain puisque vous êtes vous aimez
publier un journal un journal un journal
c'est juste avant et donc et après et
après je n'en sais rien je suis le tout
à l'heure vous parlez du commun des
mortels comme disait Cocteau moi
j'appartiens en commun des immortels
donc ma destinée va être va être commune
et je ne transformais en fauteuil après
ma mort voilà ce qui va se passer après
alors je voudrais rappeler quand même la
crise de la culture d'un arène qui est
un classique je voudrais rappeler terre
natal
de gens claires ou qui racontent un
petit peu son itinéraire
son enfance ses rapports etc chez
Gallimard alors je voudrais rappeler
Clotilde ses pattes ça date de 2 ans CD
n'est pas
consentir ont pu
vous êtes toujours sur cette position là
où là parce que j'ai senti que vous
disiez que le coup de hache pouvait
finalement c'est pas aussi rationnel que
ça moi dans mon livre n'aborde pas du
tout le consentement comme quelque chose
de rationnel et j'affirme qu'il n'y a
pas de consentement éclairé donc pour
moi ce livre c'est d'aimer pas qu'on
sentir est aussi un éloge de l'amour
très bien alors
Camille Laura Villée vous avez publié
des aventuriers de l'abstraction en deux
mots vous pouvez dire pourquoi vous vous
êtes intéressé à Bran Cusi je me suis
intéressée à Brancusi
là dans ce livre essentiellement pour le
procès qu'il intenta aux États-Unis
et qui me permettait de comprendre cette
bascule qui nous permet de passer du
XIXème au 20e siècle et la récupération
de l'abstraction du geste d'abstraction
par ce que j'ai appelé sommairement les
États-Unis mais qu'en fait qui est une
projection de l'Occident aux États-Unis
et donc c'est ça qui m'a intéressé
pourquoi ce qui s'était déroulé au 20e
siècle à travers l'art et parce qu'on
voulait appliquer assez sculptures la
taxe s'applique aux métaux ordinaire
merci merci mesdames merci messieurs au
revoir brillamment illustré ce thème de
créativité folie je voudrais remercier
l'équipe
d'lcp d'avoir permis sa réalisation et
je vous laisse avec
cette citation
à défaut d'être tous géniaux ce qu'on
regrette pour néanmoins nous sommes
doués d'une grande plasticité car nous
sommes très inachevés est-ce que vous
savez de qui c'est
non attendez un homme ou une femme
psychiatre psychiatre vivant voilà
Raphaël gaillard
[Rires]
[Musique]